[Alkış]
Hoş geldiniz hemen sizi bir ayarlayayım
mı Şöyle bir ayarlayayım biraz
interaktif olsun bugün dışarıda hava
nefis bodrumdasınız ve yapacak onlarca
alternatifiniz var ama buna rağmen
Buraya gelmeyi tercih ettiniz kendinize
yatırım yapmayı tercih ettiniz Biz
kültürüne sahip çıktınız Bence bu
alkışlanmalı ama ayakta alçalanmalı Ben
size Akşam lütfen size kendinizi
oturmayın bir sorun var
hayatta en çok kimin için değerlisiniz
Anne babam diyenler bir görebilir miyim
Sen milletle
Harikasınız sizlere oturtabilirim Tabii
ki çocuklarım çocuklarımı diğerlerimi
göreyim ve süper sizleri de alalım
kardeşim sevgilim arkadaşlarım
Kankalarım diyenleri görebilir miyim
süper sizleri de alalım
kendiniz kendi işinde değerli olanlara
bir alkışlarla alalım Harikasınız
oturabilirsiniz
bugün kodumuz biziz Peki o zaman niye
benden başladım
Çünkü o bizi oluşturan bir benden
başlıyor bakın Uçaklarda bir anons
yapılır der ki kabin basıncı düştüğünde
oksijen maskeleri düşecek ve onu
çocuğunuza takın demez Annenize babanıza
takın demez önce kendiniz kendinize
faydanız Yoksa siz kendinize değer
vermiyorsanız Siz kendinizi
sevmiyorsanız başka birilerinin sizi
sevmesi başka birine size değer vermesi
mümkün mü O yüzden her şey benden
başlıyor Bugün size üç aşamalı bir sunum
yapacağım ben biz sonra bire gideceğim
hazır bene başladık O zaman gelin bize
gidelim
tanzanya'ya gittim arkadaşlar sosyal
sorumluluk çerçevesinde
ve orada kuyu açtık suyla tanıştılar
arkadaşlar su yok Ta uzaklardan
Getiriyorlar yemek verdik Babanın biri
geldi dedi ki çocuğum bugün aç
uyumayacak Allah razı olsun
hala Tüylerim dikendi
oraya yardıma gidiyoruz ama onlardan
öğreneceğimiz o kadar çok şey var ki
bakın tişörtümün üzerinde bir yazı var
butu diye bu montu felsefesini Duydunuz
mu bilmiyorum ama
antropoloğun bir Afrika'ya gidiyor ve
orada çocuklar var
ağacın altına nefis bir meyveler koyuyor
çocuklara bir çizgi çiziyor Hadi gelin
diyor bir Yarışma yapalım diyor Buradan
oraya kim ulaşırsa diyor yarışı kim
kazanırsa bütün bu lezzetli meyveleri o
yiyecek
hazırlanıyor düdüğü çalıyor ama hiç
beklemediği bir şey oluyor çocuklar
birbirlerine sarılıyorlar ve el ele
yürüyorlar ve ağacın altında birlikte
gidiyorlar ve meyveleri birlikte
yiyorlar antropolog şaşırıyor neden
yarışmadınız diyor bakın biriniz
tamamına sahip olabilirdiniz
çocuklardan Belki de hayatının dersini
alıyor Eğer yarışsaydık sadece birimiz
kazanacaktık sadece birimiz bütün
meyveleri yiyecektik sadece birimiz
mutlu olacaktık şimdi hepimiz kazandık
hepimiz mutluyuz ve Hepimiz birlikte
yiyoruz işte Ubuntu felsefesi der ki ben
biz olduğumuzda benim
O yüzden benden bize geçmek asıl Erdem
burada başlıyor
afrikalıları geri kalmışsanız ama
öğreneceğimiz o kadar çok şey var ki
bakın yine bir Afrika deyişi var hızlı
mı gitmek istiyorsunuz
birlikte git
Daha bugüne kadar bir tane Lider
görmedim ki her şeyi tek başına başarmış
olsun Sizce şahit oldunuz mu bakın
Mustafa Kemal Atatürk
cumhuriyeti kim kurdu diyor
biz kurduk diyor bakın ben kurdum
demiyorum
cumhuriyeti biz kurduk onları yaşatacak
sizlersiniz her şey benden bize doğru
gidiyor arkadaşlar o zaman gelin Bizden
de 1'e gitme zamanı bazen 1'in gücünü o
kadar küçümsüyoruz ki ben bir kişiyim ne
yapabilirim ki
kimden ne gelir ki Ben bir öğrenciyim
Ben Bir Öğretmenim ben bir devlet
memuruyum ben ne yapabilirim ki Oysa bir
o kadar güçlü ki Cenk'i Sana affedilen
bir söz var bir mı bir nal bir atı bir
at bir komutanı bir komutan bir Ordu
diyor ve bir Ordu bir milleti kurtarır
size de bazen şu düşünce geliyor mu ya
kocaman okyanus'ta Ben sadece ufacık bir
damlayım bazen böyle düşündüğünüz anlar
oluyor mu
İşte o zaman Mevlana'yı hatırlayın
arkadaşlar diyor ki; kendini okyanusta
küçük bir damla sanla bir damdanın
içinde büsbüyük bir Okyanus Aslında
hepimizde bu güç var
bazılarımız sözle pek anlamayabiliyor o
yüzden o grup içinde özellikle video
hazırladım girin gücünü Görün bakın
hayatta yaptığımız ufacık hamla ver bu
kadar çok kitleleri etkiliyor ki bir
yerden başlıyor ve bütüne yayılıyor
gelin ufacık Bakın şu parmağım kadar bir
domino taşının bundan daha büyük bir
binayı nasıl etkilediğini birlikte
izleyelim mi birin gücünü anlayalım
[Müzik]
bu görüntüde En çok beni ne etkiliyor
biliyor musunuz bakın ilk başta kocaman
görünen insanın bile o domino taşının
bin katı olan insan bile bu kadar hafif
kalıyor ki o yüzden bazen bir kişi
olarak neleri etkileyebileceğimizin
farkında değiliz yapacağımız ufacık bir
hareket onları yüzleri binleri
milyonları etkiliyor O yüzden ben
okyanusta asla bir küçüktendayım demeyin
arkadaşlar ufacık bir hareket tüm
hayatları değişiyor ya da belki de bazı
hayatları yıkıyor bir sonraki telix
konuşmamda bir mesajla hayattaki en
büyük başarımı bir hayat kurtarmamı
anlatacağım bir mesajı bile küçümsemeyen
arkadaşlar tek bir mesajla iki Hayat
kurtarabilir misiniz
peki
benden bize bizden bire gittik bugün
benim üçüncü TED eksiğim ve tüm kalbimle
söylüyorum konusuna en sevdiğim tedx bu
oldu Biz bu kadar güzel ki
böyle kelime oyunlarını çok seviyorum
Düşünüyorum Düşünüyorum Düşünüyorum
Düşünüyorum sonunda bizi çözdüm
arkadaşlar
dikkat ettiyseniz sunumun başlığı şuydu
biz biriz buradaki biriz bir kişiyiz
anlamında ama bir iz
tarihten Bugün arkadaşlar insanların
önünde görünmez bir tabela vardır beni
değerli Hissettir herkes değerli
hissetmek önemsenmek sevilmek sayılmak
istiyor Bunun için de neler yapıyor bir
iz bırakmaya çalışıyor kiminin gönlünde
kalbinde yüreğinde ya da doğru yollardan
giderek arkasında iz bırakmak istiyor
Ben de buraya çağırdılar dedim ki
Muhtemelen bize uygun bir şeyler yaptım
ki herhalde çağırıyorlar ben acaba neyiz
bırakmış olabilirim ki diye düşündüm
özlü sözleri kimler seviyor ve görebilir
miyim böyle çok etkileniyor falan dedim
ki Ölmeden bir tane de ben yazayım belki
bundan 50 yıl 100 yıl 200 yıl sonra
Derler ki ünlü Türk düşünürüz
Bu sözü tam benlik bir inancım var
arkadaşlar ben hayatta başarısız insan
olduğuna inanmıyorum sadece
henüz nasıl başarılı olacağını
keşfedememiş insanlar olduğuna
inanıyorum Bu günden sonra ne zaman
kendinizi başarısız hissederseniz sağ
omuzunuzda bize su fısıldayan bir Ziya
Şakir Yılmaz hatırlayın
henüz
sadece henüz keşfedemediniz Ben bir
sahneye ilk çıktığımda 4 kişiden dayak
yiyordum
hiç başınıza böyle bir şey geldi mi bu
benim kötü bir sunumcu olduğum anlamına
gelir mi
dayak yemeden sunum yapmayı bilmiyordum
umuyorum bugün öyle bir şey başıma
gelmeyecek
Dolayısıyla
ilk izi burada size bırakmak istiyorum
Ne zaman başarı sorarsanız hep
hatırlayın şurada bir Ziya
henüz devam et başka neyiz bırakmış
olabilirim diye düşündüm
çok sevdiğim bir çiftçi hikayesi var Her
sene yılın en iyi çiftçisi seçiliyor ve
hep aynı Mısır üreticisi kazanıyor
sırrını soruyorlar nasıl her sene sen
kazanıyorsun Çünkü diyor ben tohumlarıma
ve diğer bütün Malzemelerimi
Komşularımla da paylaşırım ya nasıl olur
onlar senin rakibin
çita gibi saldırıyorlar Ölümü gör ne
olur al Hatırım için şunu yap falan diye
ve rahatsız ediyor onların O yaptığı
benim değişimi etkiliyor ve hep içimden
şu geçiyordu Ben bu sektörü nasıl
geliştirebilirim ama ben de onun bir
dinamiğini kullanıyorum bir şekilde
onların rakibiyim kuvvetli hayatımıza ve
bir anda evlere hapsolduk
bir eğitim açtım arkadaşlar A'dan Z'ye
Network marketingde başarı sırları 10
gün 10 saat ücretsiz sadece bağış
yaparsanız
şimdi diğer firmalardan genelde eğitim
almazlar çünkü başka firmayı kötüleyip
kendinize mi çekiyorsunuz derler kaç
kişi gelecek diye bekliyorum 5 kişi
gelse de şaşırmam 10 kişi gelse de
şaşırmam kaç kişi gelmiştir Mesela bir
tahmin alabilir miyim
yollayın
şimdi Timur koca bir gün oraya gitmiş
buna bin kırbaç fırın demiş ki Hoca
yasayı saymayı bilmiyorsun ya kırbaç
yemedin Daha ilk eğitime 500 nasıl olsun
50 bizi kutluyorum 980 kişi geldi Bu
arada çok oldu Normalde almazlar sizi
rakip görürler ama ben en başında
anlattım niyetim 100.000 kaliteli
networker yaratmak diye eğitim bitti
dediler Hocam ne olur yapın bizim
ekiplerimizde bunu da almalı bir sonraki
eğitime 1380 kişi aldı ve 4 yılda 36 bin
kişiye eğitim verdim ve her eğitime
geldiklerinde ya hocam siz başka
firmadasınız niye veriyorsunuz diyorlar
ve ben de onlara şunu söylüyorum gerçek
şu ki Hiçbirimiz kazanamayız hepimiz
birden kazanmadıkça Biz olmazsak
bütünü geliştirmezsek sadece bencil
kalırsak
olmuyor Arkadaşlar O yüzden biz biriz
diyorum Bunun dışında başka neyiz
bırakabilirim söz uçuyor konuşuyoruz ama
yazı kalıyor En azından bunca yıllık 51
yıllık hayat tecrübemi anlatayım dedim
ben Suyu elektriği yolu bile olmayan bir
köyde doğdum büyüdüm arkadaşlar İnekler
donar koyunlar aynı yerden giriyorduk
onlar solda yatıyordu bir sahada
yatıyorduk Annem ilkokul mezunu bir köy
kadındır Ama hayatta aldığım birçok
değeri ne profesörlerden ne iş
insanlarından annemden aldın rahmetli
babam köy enstitülerine mezun olağanüstü
bir öğretmendi ve onlar elimden
tutmasaydı Ben Ankara Atatürk Anadolu
Lisesi'ni kazanamaz o diye gidemez yurt
dışından astarı yapamaz ve Türkiye'de
500.000'den birinin geleceği
Uluslararası bir firmada girmeden fazla
ülkeye yönetemezdim bizim aldığımızı
verme zamanımız Yunus Emre'nin çok
sevdiğim bir sözü vardır biriktirdiğin
değil paylaştığın senindir diye O yüzden
de bizim artık verme zamanımız bende 13
baskıya ulaştı ilk kitabım 9 baskıya
ulaştı ikinci kitabım bir iz bırakayım
arkamda istedim ve Kitaplarımı yazdım
üçüncüsü de geliyor ama
en çok nerdeyiz bıraktım derseniz
5 yıl bitti 6 yıla girdi her gün ama her
gün aralıksız her gün hayattan notlar
diye bir Köşem var Her gün bir mesaj
bırakıyorum
Günaydın güzel insanlar Günaydın güzel
kalpli insanlar hayattan notlar
köşemizin bugünkü konusu diye insanların
kişisel gelişimine farkındalığına
bilincine Katkı sağlamak için mesajlar
bırakıyorum WhatsApp ve Telegram
üzerinden yayınlıyorum tele hayattan
notlar bütün eskilerinde bulabilirsiniz
benden 40.000 kişiye gidiyor onlardan
400-500.000 kişiye gidiyor Her gün 6
yıldır yorucu mu evet değer mi
Kesinlikle her gün bana onlarca mesaj
gelir Ziya bey bugün beni düşünerek mi
attınız Çünkü herkesin benzer mesajları
var Ve bugün Arkadaşlar bir şey
yapacağım canlı canlı
dinlemek ister misiniz hayattan Notlar
nasıl oluyor
Hazır mısınız gelin başlayalım o zaman
okumak için de bir göz diye ihtiyacım
var
güzel insanlar Günaydın güzel kalpli
insanlar hayattan notlar köşemizin
bugünkü konusu borcu var Arkadaşlar şu
an Bodrum'dayım ve tekex'te sahne değil
canlı canlı sahnedeyken bu mesajı size
bırakıyorum
borcu var şiirini buldum ve bayıldım
sizlerle paylaşmak istiyorum
doluysa Eğer Kazan borcu var boşa
kekliklerin sakaların tohumlara borç var
yağmura yoncaların aranın papatyaya
borcu var atlıların yapıldığı ayaya
görenin görmeyene duymayana duyanım
koşanın götürme karanlığı aydınlığın
borcu var bütünün parçalara Tom altının
hammadığına
almışların kuruya takır takır borcu var
doktorunun bulanığa balçıka ayıkların
sarhoşa divaneye akıllının borcu var
kâbî
[Müzik]
Bugün size ışıl ışıl pırıl pırıl
apaydınlık ve benim size sizin bana ama
hepimizin ona borcu olduğunuzu
hatırlayacağınız harika bir gün
diliyorum
Şu an burada bulunan herkes borcunuz var
bana
borcum var benim size
ama hepimizin borcu var arkadaşlar önce
bu dünyaya borcumuz var Biz karımla her
gün arkadaşlar bütün atıklarımızı
ayrıştırırız plastiklere ayrı kartonları
ayrı camları ayrı metaller ayrı Çünkü
doğaya borcumuz var
Biz bir hayvan severiz
sokakta çok hayvan bakıyoruz ama birine
dayanamadık Bundan tam 2 yıl önce
evimize aldık ve iki yıldır da bakıyoruz
ne hayvanlara borcumuz var arkadaşlar
ama bugün buradaysam Arkadaşlar birine
daha borcum var
Dün 22 Evlilik yıl dönümünde ve
İstanbul'da kalabilirdim kutlayabilirdik
Ama karım dedi ki git oraya onlara
borcum var O yüzden bence Karımın alkışa
ve teşekküre borcu var diye düşünüyorum
geldi konuşmamın sonuna
benim size sizin bana ve hepimizin ona
borcu var biri bin yapan on bin yapan
yüz bin yapan milyon yapan biri biz
yapan bizi bir yapan birine borcumuz var
Eğer 100 yıldır özgürce yaşıyorsak ona
borcumuz var arkadaşlar o yüzden
hepinizi bir daha almak istiyorum gelin
başımızda kocaman seslerle yapıp öyle
kapı yapın
[Müzik]
yaşadığınız bir etkinlik olsun Sizleri
seviyorum